Tom Curren the Patriots insider works
for NBC Sports in Boston joining us from
the airport Tommy how's morale today my
personal morale not that bad it's been
better
I just securities hell but I think that
overall when you got the entire
production and processed it was an
unbelievable Super Bowl Patriots give
good Super Bowl don't they yeah they do
but when you if I would have told you
this is how it was gonna play out how
surprised would you have been
I thought Falls was a lot better than a
lot of people didn't I was terrified of
the Patriots defense I tried to tell
people that this is the worst defense
they have attracted to a Super Bowl so I
was not stunned I'm stunned at the 41
but I had a 27 26 Patriots win and I was
hedging myself because I did want to
listen to people in Boston all week but
I am not surprised that the Eagles were
able to win that's that's not a good
defense over there now I thought the
Eagles had a better team but I didn't
know fools could go toe-to-toe with Bria
I mean that was to me the difference if
it folds acts like maybe the backup
quarterback folds then the Patriots win
but give him credit man they took it
right to the Patriots defense you know
they absolutely did but you know had had
I told you you know what they're going
to sit Malcom Butler down for reasons
completely unspecified and leave him
there until he rots well then you might
have thought differently and that to me
is going to be the great head scratcher
from this game and what we continue to
try and report out why was Malcolm
fought we're seated throughout the game
I mean over the course of time Malcolm
buff was been a player that bill has
rolled his eyes about at different
junctures right after he had the Super
Bowl clinching interception against
Seattle he was late for a mini camp
flight they sat him down to the entire
mini camp didn't take any on-field reps
just meetings you know this past
offseason there was you know angst
between the two and he didn't play as
well but you know this smacked of more
than he just isn't going to fit in our
plans played 98% of the place so Phil I
asked him directly is this a football
decision or a disciplinary one he said
it's football related that doesn't pass
the smell test wait so he played 98
percent of the plays but he somehow got
worse as they got to the Super Bowl
therefore he
to be seated I apparently in some
strange way and that Johnson batam OC
was a was a better option and I mean 98%
in is the highest percentage of plays
that anyone on the Patriots defense play
so it defies logic and you know we saw
the two bills earlier this week and and
you look at some of the dysfunction and
power struggles that go on and let's be
honest if the Patriots wanted their best
opportunity to do what's best for the
football team and if what's best for the
football team is winning a championship
if we put your best players on the field
and even if you decided you wanted to
keep them down for some unspecified
reason once you're starting to get
shredded by Knicks holes and have no
answers you have to change change gears
I there was some chatter going on on
Twitter and we had gotten some text
messages when I was on the set with Tony
Dungy and Rodney Harrison and John
Harbaugh of what's going on with Josh
McDaniels in the cult his job is Josh
McDaniels going to be the next head
coach of the Colts yes and I asked him
definitively in the postgame because I
usually have a pretty good source in
that arena and I did not hear from that
person at all yesterday after the
conversation started swirl so I made
sure to ask Josh immediately in the
postgame what the story was and he said
that he was going to talk about it then
but I've since been able to determine
that needs to have a conversation Phil
Belichick today he was going to talk to
Bill today and then most likely be
unveiled in Indianapolis on Wednesday I
really don't know what led to the drama
you know but Josh will be going to
Indianapolis and the Gronk situation I
know it's in the heat of the moment
he's certainly gone through injuries but
he not quite sure that he's committed to
2018 would you make of those comments I
think what I've talked to him a lot this
year in Guerrero for as much people
think that his methods and and way of
doing things is weird
he has a full disciple in Gronkowski who
told me he's never felt this good in his
life and he's never been happier I think
that this might be more of a play to see
if you can rest a little bit more money
out of the Patriots
because at this point I mean he's paid
like an average player and we saw last
night he's anything but eagle chance at
the airport this morning
now this Abdul's it's smiling as far as
I can see no one joined in no they're
still hungover they're still in bed a
great year with you we'll keep keep our
ear out eye on this and we'll talk to
you in the offseason thank you all right
Tom Curren patriots insider NBC Sports
Boston for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]